كل عام يموت ما يقرب من 5000 أمريكي في
انتظار التبرع بالكلى الآن يأتي
تقرير جديد مقلق يظهر أن أكثر
من ثلاثة آلاف من الكلى المتبرع بها يتم
التخلص منها كل عام ، وقد نُشرت هذه الدراسة الجديدة
للتو في مجلة
الجمعية الطبية الأمريكية ومراسل CNN
الطبي البارز إليزابيث
كوهين معنا الآن مع المزيد حول هذا
التقرير الجديد المثير للقلق إليزابيث ،
لماذا يتم التخلص من هذه الكلى المتبرع بها
آنا بشكل أساسي ، فهم
قلقون بشأن جودة هذه
الكلى ، دعونا نلقي نظرة على هذه
الأرقام ونقارنها بالأرقام الموجودة في
فرنسا ، لذلك في  الولايات المتحدة بين عامي
2004 و 2014 مائة وثمانية وعشرون
ألف كلية تم زرعها وما
يقرب من ثمانية وعشرين ألفًا تم
التخلص منها في أكياس.
من المرجح أن يقولوا: هذا الشخص
الذي مات والذي يمكننا أخذ كليته
كان كبيرًا جدًا نحن  لا ترغب في استخدام
كليته أو أن هذا الشخص يعاني من
أمراض معينة ولا نريد
استخدام كليته أو كليتها في فرنسا ، فهم
أقل إرضاءً ، وفي اللون الأحمر في بقية أوروبا ،
يكونون أقل انتقاءً ومؤلفو
تقول هذه الدراسة إن الأمريكيين يجب أن
يكونوا أكثر شبهاً بالأوروبيين ، فنحن سننقذ
الأرواح عندما أفكر فقط في
عدد الأشخاص الذين ماتوا في انتظار عمليات الزرع
لسماع أنه
تم التخلص من الكلى المتبرع بها ، فمن الصعب
تصديق ما إذا كان هناك أي شيء يتم القيام به
لإعادة التقييم  أو لتغيير هذا الأمر ، فأنت تعلم أن
إحدى الأفكار التي يجب على
مؤلفي الدراسة القيام بها مع الضغوط
التي تتعرض لها المستشفيات ،
حيث يتم تتبع معدلات نجاح عمليات الزرع
عن كثب ، ويمكن لأي شخص البحث عنها
عبر الإنترنت وهذا لا ينطبق على الكثير من
الأشياء في الطب ولكنك  يمكن
لمعدلات الزرع ولا يريد أي مستشفى
أن يُنظر إليه على أنه معدل نجاح ضعيف ،
لذا
فمن المرجح أن يقولوا لا لكلية قد تكون دون
المستوى